tout là-haut dans l'arbre c'est grand
papa et tout temps passe et le
petit-fils nos grands papas à inventer
il y a deux ans le mirador portatif pour
chasser le gibier que l'on fabrique à
bierset et petit fils n'ont longtemps
aux arbres ou concours épine à paris
pour montrer l'invention de grand papa
les personnes l'auteur un peu fou de ces
structures a choisi un marronnier pour y
installer sa dernière création qui cos
c'est une nacelle caché entre les
branches à 25 mètres du sol légère la
nacelle en alu est conçu pour observer
la vie animale et végétale est
exceptionnellement aussi pour voir paris
doute personnellement j'y passe beaucoup
de temps je viens dormir là avec mes
enfants ne va pas là précisément l'étude
ribes
c'est pas possible mais habituellement
en forêt on y passe beaucoup de temps on
peut mettre des hamacs au milieu là on
les a pas mis aujourd'hui mais on peut
mettre des hamacs on a une petite
cuisine on a même une installation
sanitaire très sommaire mais qui
fonctionne et donc c'est un grand
plaisir que de passer les nuits dans les
arbres